ありがとうございます
百年前ぐらい感覚なんですけど
百年前であれ やったような感じなんです
とにかくこの前はあの 二十四の因縁ですか
因ではなくてね パッチヤというものを説明していたんですね
まあおそらく 覚えていないかもしれませんし
いくらかこのちょっと思い出してもらわないとね
あの理解しにくくなりますから
パッチヤという言葉は昔も言いましたから
この因縁の言葉なんですけど
パーリ経典だったらヘートとパッチエというのは同義語で
まあ原因という意味なんですね
アビダンマになると ヘートは原因で原因で
パッチエは縁で という風にも二つに分けてるんですね
それは現代風に言えば
原因と条件という二つの意味なんですね
だから前言ったのは パーリ語
いわゆるお釈迦様の経典だったら
ヘートとパッチエっていうのはいつでも一緒に使っていたんです
まあ意味としては同じ同義語として使っていたんです
どんな原因ですかと そんなに厳密にきめ細かく哲学的に砕いて砕いて喋ろう話そうということは
それほどなかったようだと思います
そこでアビダンマの世界に発展すると
ヘートは別でパッチエは別になってしまったんですね
そこでヘートは原因で
パッチエは条件になってしまったんです
この条件論というのは
初期仏教ではそれほど発展していなかったんだから
これから条件二十四の説明半分は行きましたけど
条件は二十四あるんだと
そこでこの二十四の条件というのは
それほど論理的に合理的に整理されてないということも見えるはずなんですね
いわゆるあまりにも初期状態で
ただあの ただ材料を集めただけで
それはまあきちんと整理して
余計なものは捨てて 必要なものだけに絞るという学問的な働きというかね
その活動はそこほど進んでなかったみたいです
その前にもうアビダンマは一旦もう決めてしまって終わって
まあガタガタ状態で終わってるんです
で それはアビダンマの学者の中で
誰もそこら辺はもう考えようとはしないんですね
で 現代学者たちがもう誰にもやっぱり遠慮する必要ないんだから
ただ単に簡単に無視するだけで
伝統的にアビダンマの勉強しているお坊さんたちやら
そういう伝統的な仏教の学者のお坊さんたちやら
まあそのまま勉強してるだけで
それはもう全然考えようとはしないんですね
で だから本当に 例えばAからBが生まれるという過程では A
は原因でBは結果になるし
だからAとBの間に条件をつける必要あるかないかと
という問題はありますけど
やっぱりそういうのはまあケースバイケースであるし
ですから条件というのはそれなりに変わったりもするし
だから問題は条件はなぜ縁にならないかと
原因にならないんですか？とね
もし条件自体は原因になるならば
条件は要らなくなっちゃうんですね
だからこの まあそこら辺の考え方なんですね
だからAからBが生まれるというと
お釈迦様が言うのは A
からBが生まれるといえば
それはもう本当に絶対的な客観的な論理でなければいけません A
からBが生まれる可能性ありますよと言うたら
それ原因じゃなくなっちゃうんですね
そういう話は仏教でないAから確実にBが生まれる
それでなぜかというと A
がなければBが生まれないんだと
Bが消えてしまっちゃうと A
の存在感も存在も消えてしまっちゃうんだ
ですから この不可分な関係があるというところで
故にAからBが生まれるという考え方でおっしゃっているんですね
すごい厳しいんです で
それでそんな厳しい因果法則ではすべてのものは説明はなかなかできないんです
なぜできないかというと
因果法則は悪いんではなくて
我々にはしっかりした原因を探る
探すということは難しいんですね
でも 一つの方程式として因果法則をしっかりしているんです A
からBが生まれる そう言ったのはAがなければBが生まれないことなんですね A
がある時に限ってBが生まれる
そこでAがもし消えてしまっちゃったら B
の存在も消えてしまう
その関係でお釈迦様は因果法則をおっしゃっているんです
そこら辺は前はずっと説明してきましたしね
それは経典の中でも「イマスミン・サティ・イダン・ホーティ
イマス・ウッパダー・イダン・ウッパティティ
イマスミン・アサティ・イダン・ノ・ホーティ
イマス・ニローダー・イダン・ニルッジャティ」という四つの表現でそれはもう言ってるんですね
だからこの分離できない
ものすごいもう絶対的みたいな関係があるんですね A
とBの間では 原因と結果の間では
そこで私たちの俗的に言っている因果法則は
それで因果法則かということは問題なんですね
例えば どんなものでもいいんですよ
例えば 母が原因で子供は結果ですよと
という もう今子供がいるんだと
こちらには それは結果でしょうし
じゃあ原因はね どこかの女性ですからね
それでまあ言葉で母とかなんと言ったっても
まあ女の人がいなきゃ
また新しい人が生まれないんですね
とにかく それだったら
今ここに生まれている
確実にいる人物には 確実にその人を生んだ
まあ女性という人がいなくちゃいけないんですね
で そこは そういう場合は我々ははっきりと因果法則を言ってるんですかと
そこは問題なんです なぜかというと
じゃあ母が亡くなったらどうなるんですかね？子供死んじゃうんですかね？死なないんですね
だからそこは因果法則じゃないんですね
そこら辺が難しいのは
じゃあこの子供は あるいはこの人間が今結果としてあるんだから
じゃあ原因は何ですかと
今ここにいる人間は母親と父親がいるんだから
その原因で今いるんだというのは因果法則でなくなっちゃうんですね
だからそれ 我々の何て言いますか
アプローチとか取り扱い方が違うんですね
お釈迦様の因果法則で言えば
もし子が母が母が原因で子が生まれたというならば
母が死んだら子も死ぬはずなんです
いわゆる不可分離的な関係でないと因果法則では
だとは言えません  [笑い]そういうわけで
本当に私たちにはここに人間がいるという具体的な結果があるんです
我々も人間だから ここに私という人物がいるんですね
だからそれは結果だというならば
じゃあ原因なんですかね
原因なければ何も生まれませんし
全てのものには原因があるし
それだったら原因があるんです
それは何ですかと だから世の中でいろんなことを言うかもしれません
でも もしこの原因であなたがいるんだ
この原因であなたがいるんだと言ったというならば
その原因消えたところで私という人が死ななくちゃいけないんですね
それだったらここに私がいるということで原因を探そうと言えば
例えば心臓が動いているんだからあなたがいるんだと
違いますよ じゃあ心臓を取ってみようと
取ってとたん 人が死んじゃうでしょうし
じゃあそれだったら心臓ですかと
心臓は原因でそこに人がいる
それでまたそうでもなくなっちゃうんですね
他のものを取ったっても同じことになりますからね
だから難しいということを
それだけわかっていただければいいんです
だからやたらに因果法則っていうのは
それほどもう方程式はしっかりしているんだけど
そんな簡単にだからわかる
だから知ってるんだっていうことは言えないんですね
同じ人間の例にしてたっても
例えば酸素がずっと体に入ってるんだから
ここにあなた人間という人がいるんだと
それも確かに確かな原因で
酸素が消えちゃったら
パッと人が死んでしまっちゃう
そう見るとたくさん原因がそこで見つかるんですね
その中でやっぱり条件というものもなんとなく見えてくるでしょう
例えば心臓も肺もみんな一緒に行動してくれなきゃ
例えば心臓が頑張って
もう二年分の仕事は一日一時間でやってくれたと
それで心臓が休むと ということにはならないんですね
そうすると人が死んじゃうんです
で じゃあ私は一週間の仕事をやっぱり早くやってやって休みますからと言って
もう早く早く血液を流してあげて
それで休んじゃうと そこで肺やら胃やら腸やら他のことはまあゆっくりと頑張ればいいんだと言ったっても
そうはいかないんですね
だからこの一緒に行動しなくちゃいけないという条件があるんです
だからやっぱり因 原因だけではなくて
そちらになんかもう一つ
なんか条件というものも必要になっちゃうんですね
そういう風にこの考え方はアビダンマでは発展してないんです
ただ簡単に説明してるだけで
アビダンマテキスト アビダンマの世界で
この因果法則っていうのは
お釈迦様おっしゃっただからあまりも大きくて
あまりにも深くて これは人間には理解できる範囲のものじゃないんだと
だからといって 宇宙の生命の法則はそれしかないんですね
だからそれ理解しなくちゃいけないんですね
だからって全部全て理解できるかというと
それは不可能なんですね
だから今言った例でも
なぜここに人間がいるんですかと聞いたら
答えが見つからないんですね
母親父親が原因で私がいるんだということは
決して因果法則じゃないんです
それは私たちはこの無常を無視している
だからそう言うんですね
例えばヒヨコが卵から生まれたということは間違っているんです
決して卵からヒヨコが生まれません
で 私たちはそちらにあるこの無常ということを
いわゆる時間の流れですね
時間の流れを無視する
仏教では時間という言葉ないんだからね
仏教では無常ということ
すごいダイナミズムですね
ダイナミックですからね
このダイナミズムを見て
そこに人々は時間というもう概念作っているだけで
時間というものは存在していないんです
存在しているのはダイナミズムというものだけで
ものは停止していない
どんなものでもずっと変わって変わっていく
その変わることにまあ印入れれば時間になるだけで
それは単なるラベルだけだから
引っ越しするときは箱にいろいろ書くでしょうし
認識するために そんなもんで
それをもう書くものはそんなに大事なこと
もう AとBとCと 1と2と3とか書くっていうのは
それはそれほど意味がないんですから
ですから 時間というのはあくまでも単なる標識であって
ラベルだけであってね
無常ということだけは実際本当にあるものなんですね
そこで ここにこの人が
両親が原因でここにいるんだよと言っちゃうと
長い時間の長い変化の過程を無視しているんです
これ変化過程を理解すると
もう変化して変化していくんだから
AはBになるは  BはCになるは
CはDになるは そうやって変化していくんですから
そこに この何となくアイデンティティが消えちゃうんです A
はBになる  BはCになって
Dになって  EはFになって
それでもうZまでなったとする
故にAからZが生まれると言っちゃうとおかしいんです A
からBが生まれるんだったら
例えば必ずしもAからB生まれるという条件だったら
AがなかったらBというものは言えないと
まあまあ これは数学で簡単でしょうし
例えば一つ一つ増えるような感じで
我々は数えましょうと言った場合は
0が 0  1  2  3  4  5  6  7
8になるでしょうね それで 0が原因で10がありますと言ったら
それは間違ってるでしょうね
0からは 1なんです  1の次には2なんです
アイデンティティがないんです
もし2がなかったならば
3は作られなくなっちゃうんです
2があると次に3が現れる
例えば一人一人足すという方式で考えちゃうと
それで人々は平気でその流れの中でこれとこれとって原因だとすごい軽々と言ってしまっちゃう
例えば 5の次 6であるならば
6の次はもう7であるならば
それで9の次は10なんですね
それですごい無責任で4があるんだ
次は10があるんだということなんですね
それは間違いなんです
で それを明確に間違いは見えちゃうんですね
なぜならば 世の中で言ってる原因なんかはなくなっても
結果はそのまんまなんです
そういう風な厳しい因果法則なんですね
それであのすべてのものに対する因果法則を無条件無視にして喋ることは不可能なんですね
だから変化っていうことはちゃんと頭にあって
その角度で その何と言いますか
基準で原因を探すと そのすぐそばに原因があるんですね
離れないようにと そういう法則ではっきりと
もう頑張れば流れまででも見つかることはできますし
うん じゃあそこはまあ過去の話をまた繰り返しているだけで
で 仏教の世界では まあそんなすべてのものは理解できませんだから
我々にとっては一番必要な
大事なことだけ分析してみようと
そんなに難しいことを理解しなくちゃいけないというならば
もう不可能なことであるならば
じゃあそれだったら我々にはどうしても理解しておかなくちゃいけないことがあるんだと
それだけはもう文句言わずに理解しなさいと
ここは他のものはわからなくても構いません
例えば宇宙の構成やら
太陽がどのようにできているかないかとかね
そういうものは別に理解したんだからといって何かなるわけでもないし
理解してないんだからといって
なんか生きることは苦しくなるわけでもないし
死ぬわけでもないし ですから
この そういう科学的な世界観考えているものっていうのは
仏教ではそれはあの必要性というか
必要性というものはすごい少ないんですね
なくても大丈夫ですね
知らなくても でもどうしても知らなくてはいけないことがまたあるんです
知らなかったら私たちは不幸になって苦しみを得るんだと
それだけは知っておかなくちゃいけないということだけ選んで
お釈迦様は因果法則として語っているんですね
それに伝統の中で間違いを起こしたのは
因果法則っていうのは十二因縁だということなんですね
因果法則 因縁の教え すなわち十二因縁だと
イコールじゃないんです
この十二因縁のサイクルは
それだけはもう必ずも知っておかなくちゃいかないんだと
他のものは何も知らなくても大丈夫だと
安全だと 例えば明日雨が降るか降らないかということは
因果法則だから その因果法則を知っている人は知ってるんです
それには何年もかけていろいろこの何と言いますか
何とか学問ですか そういう勉強したりしなくちゃいけないんですね
天気予報を言うためにはね
それなりのものすごい厳しい数学やら学問やら
ありとあらゆるものを
勉強したところで それは因果法則を探してるんでしょ
それで気圧がこれぐらいで
湿度がこれぐらいで 風の向きがこれぐらいで
雲の動きはこれこれぐらいでああだこうだとか見て
おそらくここら辺に雨が降るだろうと
だからすっごい知識なんですね
それは 明日二十パーセントですよと
降水量は二十パーセントですよと言ったっても
その裏に膨大な知識が入っているんですね
科学的な知識が じゃあ問題は
それ知らない人は死ぬんですかね
本当に人の生き死には必須に何の
もうほとんど影響ないんですね
例えば天気予報を聞かなかったと
もう平気で外を出たんだ
それで出たところで もう報告の通りに雨が降ってしまったと
それでその人は家に戻れなくなっちゃって
途中で死んでしまったということは一度もないんですね
まあ雪崩とかね まあその方向無視して山登ったりして死んじゃうということはありますけど
まあ一概には言いませんだけど
一応一般的には まあそんなことはないんですね
ですから じゃあどうしても知らなくちゃいけないということは
この私たちにはどのようにしてこの苦しみが生まれるか
我々の心の悩み 苦しみ
不安定 この不満感 苛立ち
その心の虚しさですか
それはなぜ生まれるかと
それは人間にとっては大変大事な問題なんです
それはなぜ無視するかっていうこともまた問題なんです
で 無視するのはすごいバカバカらしいんですね
無視することはできないんです
気づかないだけ 例えばなんで人がもう飛行機作ったり
建物を作ったり もういろんなことをやったり
もう必死になって寝る暇もない
いろんなことをやってるんですね
それは結局 この自分 味わっている苦しみ
不満 悩み そういうものを何とかしようということなんです
でもそれを忘れて 自分が仕事をすることは大事だと
思って すごく誤解して
また大変なことになってしまっちゃうんですね
なぜそんなことをやってるんですかと
だからこれ無意識的に
これどうしても無視できない状況だから
人は何とか行動はしていますけど
その道は違うんだと ですから
この本当にこの苦しみ
悩みが生まれる この法則を
それだけは知っておかなくちゃいけないということで
それはしっかりと教えられる因果法則でもあります
だからお釈迦様は昔も今も
ある日こうおっしゃったんです
私は前も今もただ言っているのは
苦しみのことと 苦しみがいかに現れてくるかと
そのシステム だけおっしゃって教えてくるんだと
だからすごくお釈迦様の言葉っていうのは明確で
はっきりしていて こういうまあごまかしは何もないし
すごいしっかりしているし
この例えばなぜ仏教で神秘的な話とかね
そういうのはまあ仏教の文化の中に入り込んでますけど
お釈迦様の言葉にはもうないんですね
お釈迦様の言葉だけ 余計なところをハサミで切って
お釈迦様の言葉だけ取ってみると
もう何もないんですね
そういうのは だからそういう話とかね
まあ神秘的な話とかね
まあ形而上学的な話とか
単なるごまかしであって
で 我々はそういうことを聞きたいだけ
例えば人間っていうのは力がないもろいものなんですね
そこで頭の中でスーパーマンの概念が生まれてくるんですね
自分の体の上に電車が走っちゃっても
もう大丈夫やと立ち上がったら何の傷痕も傷もないんだと
かすり傷もないというふうな
このスーパーマン現象とかが生まれてくるんですね
だからこの我々知っている天国の話
あの世の話も もう全てそういうふうな
このもう呪文の信仰も
先世実の信仰も そういうふうに生まれてくるもので
そういう話はお釈迦様はよしましょうと
そんなことを知ったっても
あなたの苦しみは消えるわけじゃないんだ
先世実のプロになったんだからといって
精神的に人の苦しみ消えるわけじゃないんですね
ですから この十二因縁というのは
お釈迦様がおっしゃったこの因果法則の一つのアプリケーションですね
お釈迦様はその唯一一つしかアプリケーションにしてないんです
時々たまたま他のところにもそれは応用したところはあるんです
かえってお釈迦様何喋っても因果法則のその基準からは外れません
いわゆるしっかりとこういうわけで
こういうことでこうなりますよという話しか喋れません
嫌だから嫌ですよとかね
そういう話はないんです
それだけでこの そこで十二因縁というのは
一応自然の流れで それだけ因果法則という風になってましたけど
別にお釈迦様おっしゃったのはそういうものというよりは結構大変ややこしい教えなんです
その中で出てくるのはこの条件の話です
だからこの体のなぜここに私がいるんですか？と言えば
ここに心臓が働いてるんだから
それははっきりした原因ではないんだけどね
それもちょっとおかしいんだけど
一応仮に言うならばね
心臓が動いてるんだからと
肺が活動してるんだからとかね
と言ったならば そういうものはやっぱりずっと一緒に活動してくれないと
ここに私がいるということは消えてしまっちゃうんですね
脳が働いているんだからとか何とか言えるんですけどね
そこをこの活動が停止しちゃったら私もいない
だから原因のように見えるんですね
それでもしっかりした原因ではないんだけど
そこでこの条件の二四の中で
このこの前半分ぐらい終わりましたけど
今日おそらく十三だと思います
カンマパッチ カンマパッチっていうのは業ですね
説明がなかなかできないし
この 2番のヴィパークパッチ
まあ一応いくらか 2番目ではなくて
これ十五と十六だと十三と十四
私も説明がわからない
なんでカンマが条件になりますかとかね
まあ経典によると アビダンマによると
カンマっていうのは人の意志ですね
業っていうのは 何か行動ね
身口意の行動したがる気持ち
したくなる その気持ち自体が業と考えているんですね
ですから 業の場合はすごいわかりやすいんだけど
例えば手を伸ばしたということは手を伸ばしたいという気持ちしかないんですね
そこで手を伸ばしたところで
そこに人がいて その人に当たってしまったと
だから人をぶったという罪には問われません
見たらあんたあの人ぶったんじゃないかということを人が言うかもしれませんだけど
その人にはそういう気持ちはなかったんですね
ただ手を伸ばしただけ
それで逆に人を殴りたい
でもそれは分かったら困るんだから
ちょっと手を伸ばすふりをするという
そこで いや 私は手を伸ばすだけです
で言ったっても 気持ちが人を殴る気持ちでしたから
そこでその人は人を殴ったことになるんですね
だけど そこら辺は分かりやすいんです
業っていうのは 責任持たなくちゃいけない
自分の行動の自分の行為の責任
本人が持たなくちゃいけない
責任はもう絶対的にその人のものになっちゃうんですね
で それはいくら時間経っても無常だからといって逃げるわけにはいきません
で 借金と同じなんです
その行動はもう金取った
それでそれで終わっちゃいますけど
借りがあるということは
まあ払わない限りはずっとあるんですね
ですから そこは別に実体なくても存在するでしょ
その条件状況だけは 人からお金借りたならば
まあこの借りた人が病気になろうか
年取ろうか あるいはいろいろ何て言いますか
あれはいろいろ手術を受けたりしてね
体いろいろ変化させたりするでしょうね
例えば男の人がお金借りたりする
それから手術して女の人になってしまっちゃうんだ
そういう何をやっても
借りたお金が返さなくちゃいけないでしょ
そういうことで この業っていうのは大体そんなもので
逃げることはできません
自分が行った行為だから責任がある
責任が入っちゃうんですね
この責任感なんですね
業っていうのは そこで
ヴィパーカっていうのはイジュクの因縁で
ヴィパーカっていうのは大体これアビダンマだけに
限って説明しなきゃいけないんですからね
もう十人の中だけしか説明できませんですけど
例えば 私たちはここで初めて人間として生まれる時
生まれる瞬間で 人が生まれる瞬間というのは
おなかの中に生まれるんですね
出産ではないんです で
その瞬間で初めてこの世の中で心の機能がスタートするんですね
で その一番最初に現れる心の機能っていうのは
認識機能っていうのは
やっぱり前の何か原因でないと現れないんですね
で これ例えば心と体 ナーマとルーパが全く別なものだと認識して理解しているのはそういうわけで
ルーパからナーマが生まれるわけは絶対ないんだと
ルーパっていうのは物質で
物質から物質しか生まれません
そこら辺はもうしっかりと考えているんですね
だから 心の流れは別のエネルギーの流れとして考えているんです
分かりやすく言えば 例えば人形
機械的な人形を作って
その人形のスイッチを入れたら
その人形は手を上げたり下げたりすることはできます
で 私たちにも手を上げたり下げたりすることはできます
私たちの手も機械で動いていますが
その機械を動かしているのは我々の感覚なんですね
動かしたいという感覚があって動いているんですね
だから 機械の人形の手の動かし方と我々の手の動かし方が働きとしては違うんです
だから似ているものは機械でできます
例えばピアノを演奏することもロボットに頼むことができます
そういうロボットも作ってやったんだからね
カメラ 2つか 1つか分かりませんだけどね
頭の中につけちゃって
それで楽譜を読み取って
コンピューターで計算して
それ信号は指にいろいろ機械いっぱい作って
それでもうピアノを演奏してくれる
でも同じことを人間もやる場合は
人間の場合はそれ心でやってるんですね
感覚でやってるんですね
ですから その働きは別に物質的な働きでないと
もうはっきりと仏教では区別しているんですね
そこで心だけ別に区別して認識すると
心の法則っていうのは
やっぱり今心があるということは
前に原因がなければいけませんし
ところだから前の原因も心的でなものでないといけないんですね
前に石があって 次に心があるというと
なんかすごくめちゃくちゃになっちゃうんですね
それだったら今のある物体も突然命入ってしまって
生きがい生きる生き物になってしまって逃げ回る可能性もありますからね
それはもうありえないものだからね
それであの心の法則っていうのはいとも簡単で
前の心があって それ消えると次の心が生まれる
だから簡単単純な法則なんです
1つ消えると その代わりもう 1つ作ると
で 私たちにはそれは心はあんまりにも早すぎたからね
早すぎだから理解できないんだけど
だから瞑想させちゃうんですね
瞑想させて集中してもらうんですね
集中 あれは特別訓練しないと心はもうなかなか 1か所に留まることはないし
すごい強引に訓練して集中しちゃうと
1つのものだけ認識することはできるようになるんですね
ほんのわずかな時間でも
それほんのわずかな時間でも
1つのものだけ認識すると
その瞬間で他のものは何も知ることはできないということがわかるんです
だから 本人にとってはそれは存在しない状態になるんです
そこで じゃあそれも見ようと思ったら
これ消えちゃうんですね
例えば瞑想して心の働きだけ見られるようになったとする
そうすると体を見ていない物体を
その人はどう感じるかというと
体が消えたんだと 感じるのは心だから
あれは体が消えたんではないかと感じる
そこで体が消えたと